-Finally
"Thor: Love and Thunder"
is almost in theaters.
[ Cheers and applause ]
I know.
I'm excited.
And ahead of the release,
we thought that we'd share
some fun facts about Marvel's
famous God of Thunder.
This is
"Thor: Little Known Facts."
-♪ Thor ♪
♪ Little known facts ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
But first, I'm going to need
someone to help me.
His new movie
"Thor: Love and Thunder"
is in theaters on July 8th.
Please welcome Chris Hemsworth.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Hello.
-Chris!
-How you doing?
-How are you, bud?
-I'm very well, mate. Very well.
-Thank you so much
for doing this.
Chris, our researchers found
some interesting facts
about Thor to help fans get
ready for the big premiere.
-Of course, they did Jimmy.
I was very impressed with what
you guys found.
This stuff -- it's stuff that I
didn't even know.
Only hard-core comic book fans
do, so it's very exciting.
-I think our research team
did a great job.
Let's get started with some
little-know facts about Thor.
Here we go, I'll go first.
Did you know that Thor's father
is Odin, but his godfather
is actually
Sean "P. Diddy" Combs.
[ Laughter ]
-It's true. It's true.
It's actually the plot
of this film.
So we shouldn't say too much
about it.
-Don't spoil it.
Why don't you give me one?
-Asgardians prolong their lives
by eating
the Golden Apples of Idunn.
The Asgardians learned of the
apples in an article on Goop.
-Wow.
I didn't know they had Goop.
-Gwyneth Paltrow link there.
-Yeah, I love those articles.
How about this one?
Thor's full name is actually
Courtney Thorne Smith.
Did you know that?
-Can you believe it?
-Yeah.
these are all fascinating.
-In this one, Thor has to get a
job because he lost all of his
money on "Thored Ape" NFTs.
-Oh, it's tough.
-He's a big metaverse guy.
-It's a tough market right now.
How about this one?
Everyone knows Chris Hemsworth's
brothers Liam and Luke,
but he also has a fourth brother
named Clemsworth Hemsworth.
He plays bass with
the Jonas Brothers.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Clemsworth, is a guy.
-He's good.
Talented, talented,
talented guy.
Why don't you give me one?
-Thor's hammer is named Mjolnir.
His belt is named is Megingjord.
And his pecks are named
Bert and Ernie.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-There you go.
That's what I'm talking about.
My thanks to Chris Hemsworth.
His new movie "Thor: Love and
Thunder" is out July 8th.
Thank you, buddy.
Always good to see you.
-You too. Thank you.
-He's the greatest.